>> Thanks for coming.
I'm very happy to introduce
Frank Wang from MIT.
He's at PhD student of
the MIT CSAIL advised
by Nickolai Zeldovich
and James Mickens.
Frank works at
the intersection of
systems and applied
cryptography.
And today he's going
to be telling us about
his dissertation work
on protecting
privacy in Web services.
>> Thanks. Hi everyone,
I'm Frank and I'm
a PhD student MIT CSAIL,
and today I'm going to talk
about some my PhD research on
building systems that protect
sensitive user data
in Web services.
So, whenever users interact
with Web services like Google,
Facebook, or Yelp they
provide their data.
This data is
important and valuable
both for the Web service
and the user.
The user is willing to provide
her data because she
obtains value from it.
For example, when a user
provides her Fitbit data,
she can track
her health and exercise,
as well as compare it
against other users.
I mean, similar a user
provides her data
to Facebook so that she can more
easily learn about
the social lives of
her friends and similarly
share her social life.
Also buying things off
Amazon and thus giving
your preferences can lead
to better product
recommendations.
But that's on the user side.
So, on the other side,
Web services actually gain
a lot of value from user data.
As we know, Facebook has data on
your preferences so you can
make more money off ads
by targeting them better.
Amazon can better provide
product recommendations that
can lead to more purchases.
So, however there's a big
security and privacy problem.
Web services often handle
sensitive user data insecurely.
So, at a very high level this
is how a Web service works.
A user submits a request
on her mobile device,
browser, or some client
to a service.
The service processes
that request which might involve
storing some user data
or performing
some computation and
returns a response.
So, now service one has
some user data or has
done some computation.
And service one can then also
forward some of the data to
a second service
or second service
might want to access data
from the first service.
So, as you can see there are
many channels where user data
can leak or be compromised.
For example, data can leak on
the user side
through the browser
to an unauthorized application.
Not properly handling
a query can also leak
private information about
a user to a service.
Unauthorized services can also
attempt to access the data
and the data can leak from
the services' database and
kind of the list goes on.
And this happens many times
because Web services
often lacked cryptographically
secure mechanisms
to protect private user data.
So, kind of my research is very
focused on solving
these types of problems.
More broadly, it is
on building practical,
secure mechanisms to protect
sensitive user data in
large scale Web services.
So, naturally much
of my work lies
at the intersection of
systems and cryptography.
Because, as I'll show
in the next slide,
in most of my research I apply
crypto tools to build
systems that help
prevent these data leaks.
So, this is difficult for
two main reasons in my opinion.
First, most of these
advanced crypto techniques
are relatively new
and not well studied.
And second, It's
difficult to apply
these crypto techniques in
a practical way to achieve
the system's goals.
So, as a result,
I spent a lot of time with
cryptographers and, you know,
I'm excited to continue
these collaborations across
these two communities.
So, recall the high
level representation
of a user-web
service interaction.
So, this is how
my research projects aim
to prevent data leaks
in some of the channels.
So, many of the projects apply
crypto techniques in
a practical manner
to prevent these leaks.
So, Veil is the
first platform that
allows users to provide
stronger private
browsing semantics.
It focuses on
client side data leakage
and it's based on the premise
that private browsing modes,
like incognito mode,
are leaky and
extremely difficult to
fix in the browser alone.
My next project is Splinter,
which allows for private
user queries to Web services,
like Yelp or Google Maps
in a practical way.
And my next few
projects are more
focused on server side leakage.
So, Cobweb and Riverbed
solve the problem that
the privacy policies
for data and
its derivatives are hard
to enforce to
compact applications.
So, we developed a practical
information flow control system
to deal with this in
modern Web services.
And finally, Sieve provides
cryptographically enforced
access control for user data.
It's motivated by the fact that
data is constantly shared
between applications.
So, for today's talk I
will focus on Splinter,
which had a strong
collaboration between
cryptographers and
systems researchers.
I worked with Shafi
and Vinod at MIT for
the cryptography and Matei
for the systems aspect.
And the reason I'm focusing
on this project is, first,
we thought it was
really exciting to take
a relatively recent
cryptographic tool and
build an efficient end-to-end
private query system.
And second, I enjoyed getting
two different groups of
researchers and
together to work on
a project they typically
would not work on.
So, the systems people
did crypto work and
the crypto people did
some systems work.
So, with this
collaboration we're able to
execute on this project
relatively quickly
and efficiently.
So, here's an outline
for the rest of my talk.
I'll talk about Splinter,
the motivation, threat model,
how we execute Splinter queries,
and finally the evaluation
and some future work.
So, to kind of
motivate Splinter,
suppose a user wants to query
a database to retrieve
records or perform analytics.
Some examples of this
include searching for
a patent to ensure your patent
hasn't been published.
Looking for stock prices,
medical databases to find
certain diseases or doctors,
and Expedia to find
a flight for a trip.
These queries leak
sensitive user information.
For example, searching
for a patent on
an outside database can reveal
ideas in your invention.
An investors query
might indicate
whether they plan to
buy or sell a stock.
Even searching a medical
database to learn more about
diseases and doctors could
reveal and leak
potential health problems.
And finally, Expedia could raise
the prices of
frequently search flights.
So, one naive way to
solve this problem,
it's just for the user to
download the database from
the service and perform
the queries locally
on her machine.
I mean, however these databases
like Google Maps, stocks,
and patents are usually
hundreds of megabytes
and the user has to
re-download any updates which
leads to a high
communication costs.
And that's especially
problematic
for users on mobile phones.
So, this brings up the question,
how do we build
a practical system that can
help keep user's
queries private?
So, to accomplish this
with our system, Splinter,
we considered a
slightly modified
setting with more servers
and replicated databases.
More formally, Splinter
has two principles.
The user and multiple
autonomous providers and
each provider has a copy
of the same public database
in clear text.
We assume, at least one provider
does not collude
with the others.
So, on the Web many
of these databases are
public such as
OpenStreetMap, stocks,
flights data, and, you know,
for efficiency they are already
replicated across
many providers.
Also, unlike in
the naive approach,
we pushed some computation
to the providers.
So, what happens in Splinter?
So, user splits her query into
multiple parts and sends
them to the provider.
And each provider processes
its share of the query
on the database records and
then sends back a response.
So, the user takes
all the responses
from the providers
and combines them to
get the result without
the providers learning
their original query unless
all the providers collude.
So, in Splinter,
our queries have
low communication cost,
computation, and
number of round trips.
And this allows us achieve
more practical performance
compared to previous systems.
And to do this, we use
a recent cryptographic
primitive function
secret sharing to achieve this.
And I'll talk more
about how this
works later in the talk. Yes?
>> So, here you
assume [inaudible]
one provider who doesn't
collude to with others,
so this will be secure, right?
>> Yes.
>> So, if you relax
the assumption
saying there's more than half
where they don't collude,
will that give you
a better performance or with
a different crypto primitive?
>> It's not clear what this
crypto primitive
would look like.
I mean, I think,
you can imagine,
we explored using
kind of information
theoretic private
information retrieval.
That kind of has
different models.
That has assumes
like a majority,
or like a minority,
doesn't collude else's models
where one doesn't collude.
But I think function
secret sharing allows us to
kind of get a lot there like
good communication costs
and expressiveness.
I mean, there could be kind
of something in the middle.
I mean, I think that
crypto technique
just doesn't exist yet.
I mean, something worth looking
into unlike
the theoretical side.
Because now I've given you
an overview of Splinter.
I want to more explicitly
state our threat model.
So, the data on the providers,
it's not sensitive
and in clear text.
We assumed that providers are
passive adversaries and try
to learn the users query,
and they don't tamper with
the query or the data.
And we also assume that
at least one provider does
not collude with the others.
So, the contributions of
this work are the following.
Splinter, which is
a private query system
for public databases that
scales to realistic
applications.
We are the first system that
uses and extends
function secret sharing,
FSS, with new protocols to
run complex private queries.
We develop optimizations to
lower CPU and
communication costs,
and we evaluated our system
on realistic applications,
which led to response times
of less than 1.6
seconds for databases
with millions of records.
And we have to have
up to an order of
magnitude fewer round-trip times
than prior systems
that are based on
cryptographic techniques such as
PIR and Garbled circuits.
So now, I've given you
a motivation and threat model.
I'll move on to how
we actually apply
FSS to execute Splinter queries.
So, here's the query format
that we support.
We support a subset of SQL
specifically projections,
limiting filters,
aggregates, and no joins.
We support queries in
the following format.
Select multiple
aggregates or projections
from a single table
where certain conditions
hold and group by or order
by multiple expressions
with a specific limit.
It's important to note
that Splinter's goals is
to keep the
sensitive information
in the condition private,
and shown by in
the red box with the lock.
And so, a more
concrete example is,
if we were to search for
the top 10 cheapest flights
for a certain route on Expedia.
This is kind of
an example query we'd run,
and the condition route
equals five,
which is just an encoding
of the route,
leaks information about
the route we are searching for.
And so, we want to
hide the number five.
And so, in the next slide,
I'll show you what conditions
Splinter supports.
And later I'll show
you how we execute
this exact query while
hiding five and
preserving privacy.
So, Splinter supports
three types of
conditions in the query filter.
The following table is
important because the algorithm
that Splinter executes for
query aggregates depends
on the condition type.
And so, the three conditions
are equality-only,
intervals, and disjoint ORs.
The form of the condition
is in the right column.
E represents the column name,
and Ci can be inequality
or interval condition.
So, Splinters is
the first system to use function
secret sharing FSS as
a building block
for private queries.
But, before we describe how
to actually execute
these queries,
I'll describe some of
the important features of FSS.
So, the goal of FSS is
to evaluate a function in
a distributed fashion without
the providers learning
the actual function.
And so, how does
this happen in FSS?
So first, a function is
divided into k shares,
and these shares have
the following properties.
Each share can be
evaluated quickly,
the sum of the shares
evaluated on
an input is equal to the input
the original function
and given all but one share,
someone can't recover
the original function f. So,
there are efficient
constructions for two cases.
First, point functions,
which is a function
that evaluates to
one if x is a specific value
and zero otherwise.
And for Interval functions,
is a function that
evaluates to one if x is
between two numbers
and zero otherwise.
So, as you can see, kind
of at a very high level,
we want to transform
the query conditions into
FSS supported functions,
and execute them on
the database with
specific protocols on top
of that to preserve privacy.
And in the next few slides,
I will give you
some specific examples,
how we go about
executing these queries.
So, to better understand how FSS
works in the context
of Splinter,
I'll start with how we
perform a COUNT query.
And so, suppose we
want to know the number of
flights for a certain route.
For simplicity, let's
consider a subset of
a flight database with
two columns, route and Price.
Each provider holds a copy
of this database like that.
And so, suppose we want to
count the number of flights.
Where the route is
five but we don't want
the provider to learn that
we're querying for route five.
And so, for reference when
we run this specific query,
the answer to
this question is two.
And so, how does Splinter
perform this query?
Well, first, we
need a function that
evaluates to one if
the input is five and
zero otherwise and
then the user uses
FSS to convert this function
into function shares for
the number of providers.
And in this example,
there are two providers.
Some important properties
of the function shares,
f1 and f2 are that one of x
plus f2 of x equals f of x.
And having either f1
or f2 doesn't reveal
any information
about the original
f which contains
a user's sensitive information,
our value of five.
So, each provider applies
its share to each route record
in the database,
and it's important to note
that the provider
has to scan through
every entry in the database or
else we leak user information.
So, here are some examples of
values that can be output
by the function share.
All these operations are done
modulo and integer
field but in our case,
we use negatives for
illustration purposes.
And so, each provider
sums together
the outputs of
the evaluated functions
and sends them back to the user.
In this case, one provider
sums up 21 and sends back 21,
and the other one
sums up negative
19 and sends that
back to the user,
who then sums them together
to obtain the answer
to our original query.
And so, why does this work?
Recall that f1 of x plus
f2 of x equals f of x.
This means in our example,
given our function f of x
equals one if x equals five.
Across providers,
the values will sum to one,
if the route is equal to five,
and since f of x equal
to zero if x is not five,
across providers
the values will sum to
zero if the route
is not five. Yes?
>> Can f1 be zero?
>> I mean.
>> [inaudible]
>> Yes, what it outputs
is actually random.
So, it can be zero.
It's modular integer field,
so it's like zero to n -
1 in the integer field.
An integer field has
n elements, right?
And so it can be zero to n - 1.
I mean, I use negative numbers
here just to kind
of make things easier but
it's all mod something.
>> Can you do it
with real numbers?
>> So real numbers are
a little bit trickier.
You have to convert them into
an integer first or you have
to hash them in some way.
FSS works best when
the kind of input is
an actual integer.
I mean, real numbers,
you can imagine ways to map
some real numbers to
integers potentially.
Cool. Great. So now,
suppose that we want
to perform a SUM query,
say because we want to find
the average price
for a specific route.
So, how do we do this?
It's an extension of COUNT,
and so we want to use
the same setup except
we want to do a
SUM(price) instead of
COUNT in the SQL query.
On the providers, we do
the same thing as COUNT,
except in addition to
evaluating the function share
on each route record
we also multiplied the output of
the function share with
the corresponding price.
And because FSS is
an additive function,
this essentially
has the effect of
scaling the matching
records by the price.
And then each provider
adds up all the results,
sends them back to the user,
who sums them up, and gets
the final answer to their query.
So now, we've seen
how to do two types
of additive queries,
COUNT and SUM.
Let's look at how we do
a non-additive query,
MIN, with an
Equality-Only condition.
So, consider the same table
as the count in SUM query,
and now we want to
find the price of
the cheapest flight with
route five and height five.
Now, we use the same
function as before,
generate shares, and send
them to the provider.
So using FSS is not enough
to execute this query in
this particular case because
it emphasizes
an additive function.
So it's not clear
how it's directly
compatible with
non-additive queries like MIN.
And so, how do we
perform this query?
So our observation is
that the provider can use
the public information in
the user-provided query
to form another query.
More specifically,
in our example,
the provider performs
"SELECT MIN(price),
GROUP BY route" and
this query creates
an intermediate table,
which has the MIN price
for each distinct route.
And because this table
was created using
a query based on
public information,
no sensitive user
information is leaked.
And computing this table
takes linear time.
Then we do the
same thing as SUM.
Apply the function shares to
all the records in
the route column
in the intermediate table,
and multiplied the MIN(price)
column with the output
of each function share.
Each provider then adds up
all these values and sends
the response back to the user.
So, now let's try
to do a MIN query
with the different
condition type intervals.
So again, using FSS is
not clear here because
of the MIN aggregate.
But now, also
the condition now contains
multiple values that we
want to match rather
than a single value,
like the quality-only condition.
And so one naive way to
perform this is to just
perform the previous protocol we
described, a multiple values.
But that doesn't scale
well to larger interval
ranges because we now have to
do many of these round trips.
So how do we kind
of do this with
a limited number of round trips?
And so let's say
we want to select
the minimum price of
several similar routes.
And so now I'll provide
a high-level overview
of this protocol.
So first, each provider uses
the public information in
the query and they compute
a sorted table T using
the SQL query "SELECT route,
price ORDER BY route".
Then, the providers find
the MIN price on
power-of-2 intervals in
the sorted table T. So here
for illustration purposes
and simplicity,
we just showed
the price column in
our table T. So
those numbers just
represent the price column that
correspond to the sorted routes.
So for our sorted table
of eight values,
we create size two up
to size eight intervals.
And so for the size
two intervals,
you can see we just look
at neighboring pairs
of values in T and
pick the minimum,
and then we continue
this process
up to size eight intervals.
And so we have a small table
but you can kind of
see how we can do this
iteratively for
larger tables. Yes.
>> Your route number
is being consecutive?
>> So our route numbers,
so we sort this ahead
of time. So, yeah.
>> So it means you can't have
huge gaps in your rep numbers
or something like that.
Like one of them have a 101,
three, 24, something like that.
You would have to fill in?
>> Oh, no, no. We don't. So this
is just the price column.
So the route just kind
of corresponds to this.
Your route can kind
of be any range.
>> A user needs to know
how to sort of map?
Okay, so then we'll
be as deep though as,
it'll be sort of as if,
if the user doesn't know,
I guess, what
the route's numbers
are, then do you have a problem?
>> No, so the user doesn't
actually have to know
anything about this table.
Now, I kind of show,
the next slide tells you
what the server does to
kind of get the right value.
So here the routes can
be kind of anything,
like the routes
can have big gaps
or not big gaps or can
be close to each other.
I mean, it doesn't matter
because we just sort
this ahead of time.
The server knows
we're doing a MIN with
an interval query and kind
of performs a sorted
where it caches it and so,
this is kind of what the server
does in the first step,
is kind of create these up
to size eight intervals.
In the next slide I'll show
you kind of what the server
does to return
the values back to.
>> So for size two intervals,
like that second line,
the first bucket will
be whatever the first
two route numbers are,
no matter if it be one
and the 101 if that's
what they were, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah. I'll show
in the next one how we kind
of resolve a lot of this.
>> To get into that,
we have this price, 0, that's
because that route is missing?
>> I mean, this is an example
I made. Or it's free.
>> But you won't have a
zero filled in for
a route that is missing?
>> Sorry?
>> So all these are eight,
they all have a route.
>> Yeah.
>> What if you have
only seven routes?
What do you do with
the eighth item?
>> I mean yeah, so
if I only have eight,
I mean if there was
kind of like a gap here,
you kind of still
create up to size
eight intervals. You
can still do this.
So here, let's say we're
missing zero, then
this will just be one.
Right I mean we kind
of just size like that.
And so, I mean, It's
definitely easier
if its power-of-two
but you kind of imagine
if it goes out here,
like we want to
do it to the next.
So if there are nine,
there will be up to, like,
size 16. Okay, cool.
So, yeah. Then the algorithm
proceeds in two rounds.
So in the first round,
the user wants to find
the maximum and
minimum indices in
the price column where the route
is between one and five,
in this particular example.
And this requires two parallel
FSS point function queries.
And so, for this example,
we find out that
the MIN and MAX database indices
for those specific routes are,
say, three and six.
And so, in the next round,
the client selects at
most two intervals of
each size to cover
the target interval
and returns a result.
And in this case we
select two intervals
from the sorted table T,
marked in yellow, and one
from the size two interval,
marked in yellow, to
cover the targeted
interval three to six,
and then we choose
two and zero from
the sorted table T. So it's
important to note that,
you know, we can't just query
these three yellow
values directly.
If we do, the adversary will
learn our interval conditions.
So that's why we have to issue
FSS queries for
each interval table,
so that the server doesn't
know what we're searching for.
But the nice thing is
that we can just do
this in parallel.
And so, in the last
few slides I showed you
how Splinter can execute
additive aggregates
like COUNT and SUM,
and non-additive
aggregates like MAX, MIN,
and TOPK for equality-only
interval conditions.
I won't have time to
describe how would you do
non-aggregates with
disjoint OR conditions.
But at a very high level,
we use private binary search and
sampling on top of FSS
to handle these queries.
So now I've talked to you
about how we execute queries,
I'll show how
these queries perform.
So here are just some
information about
the three applications that
we built on top of Splinter
and their datasets,
such as number of
rows and sizes of
evaluation setup and it's
important to note that we
use real datasets in
these applications.
Yes.
>> With respect to the size,
are those devices compress,
are those sizes for
the compressed dataset,
or just the raw dataset?
>> The raw dataset. So here,
I'll present the SQL
queries who would
perform on our case
study applications.
And our goal was to test
various types to
Splinter supported
queries on different datasets
to show Splinter's
expressiveness.
So for Yelp, we
evaluated three queries.
Our first query, we counted
the number of Thai restaurants.
The next query, we executed for
the top ten Mexican
restaurants near me.
And finally, we find
the best restaurants from
a subset of categories.
So for flight search,
we look for an average price
between a source and
destination pair,
for a certain month, and
the top ten cheapest flights
for source and destination pair.
And for map routing,
we find paths and nearest nodes.
So these queries assume
transit new branding,
which is a map routing technique
that's compatible with Splinter.
But I won't go into
too much detail on how
that works exactly here.
So here is a table that
summarizes Splinter's
performance.
There are few important
things to note.
We evaluate our system using
two and three providers because
the performance especially
the communication costs
differs based on
the number of providers.
So let's dive into
the case studies with Yelp.
You can see that
these queries have
pretty short response times,
the communication costs are low.
However, with three providers,
we have slightly higher but
still reasonable
communication costs.
These costs are still lower than
downloading the whole database.
And one thing to note is that,
the best rated restaurant
in the category,
subcategory, has 11 round trips.
And this is because it requires
a max query on a disjoint
or condition which
uses this private binary
search algorithm that I didn't
describe but end up being
log N of round trips,
where N is the size
of the database.
>> Explain why
the communication cost
go from two to three,
the increased levels of
ten times and otherwise,
hundred times, and otherwise,fifty
times or five times.
>> Yeah. So on the protocol
for kind of like dealing
with the three and more server
is different than
the two server.
So the two server has a
slightly different
like FSS protocol.
We didn't modify any
of the FSS protocols
but the two server one is a
little bit more efficient.
It's little bit
slower actually in
some cases but a
three three one,
it just has more communication
because the factor is different
in the protocol itself.
>> Is still quite high, right?
I mean, it's not much better
than downloading the FSS.
>> I guess in this case,
it's still pretty good.
I think if you look
at the account,
for example, it's
only 30 kilobytes.
>> But the other one
like two megabytes,
I'd only be able to do
like ten queries, right?
So it will be
roughly 23 megabytes which
was the size of the database.
>> Yeah. But there are updates
like on the database, right?
>> Okay, sir.
All the updates have to
be rocking
transactions globally.
You have to do
global transaction as credit
for direct customer
to an update.
>> Yes. I mean you don't have
to do our cross every day.
So here, say we have
100 servers. You'll
need to pick three.
So only those three
have to be synced up.
And so maybe you have
like these mirror sites,
maybe you always tell
people like these
three are synced up,
or these two are synced up,
and so it only has to be
synced up between the site.
>> So it's like as the size
of the data increases,
are you better, is your slope
better than downloading
the database?
So as the datasets
of the day increases,
you're going to take
more and more time
to download the database.
>> Right.
>> Okay. So that's
going to increase at
some slope which is
probably near with
the size of the database.
What is your slope as
you increase the side?
For that, that will be certain.
>> Okay.
>> It doesn't come off from
state law unfortunately.
>> Okay. Yeah.
>> So a couple of
follow-up questions.
So is this Yelp or
is it Yelp clone?
>> Yelp clone.
>> What is Yelp clone?
>> It's just like the Yelp
academic database I know.
>> Is that a representation
of real database?
>> We try to make it as
close to a real database
as possible.
What Yelp gave out
is like what their
database looks like.
>> Okay. And then,
a second question is how do
you arrange for
these multiple providers?
Who do you see in the real world
being these providers?
>> Yeah. So I think
in the real world,
you could imagine either someone
volunteering to kind
of host some of this,
and then Yelp kind of
uploads that and pay
a fee or like Yelp itself
has like a private version,
and then as a result,
they kind of host these
multiple databases
that they already
have and you kind of paid
Yelp to kind of issue queries,
kind of like how
a lot of APIs work now
like when you make
API calls, they charge you.
You can imagine
making these types of
API calls to Yelp
and Yelp charges you
but they're saying, hey,
we're not collecting
information but we need to run
the servers here and we're
like you pay for this.
>> And those providers are
providing a service for
Yelp but isn't that
in conflict with
the non-collision assumption?
Because on the one hand, you are
assuming that this
sort of talk to
Yelp because Yelp
has been paying
them to providing API service.
On the other hand, you're
assuming non-collusion, right?
>> Right. Collusion in the sense
that like they're
colluding with each other,
kind of observe this.
So our subsidies somewhere like
be monitoring and
sharing information.
I guess ideally, you
would have two or three
different types of providers,
there'll be multiple
people will host
this multiple API services that
are independent or someone
runs as a volunteer.
>> Can I ask
a very related question?
>> Yeah.
>> So for the FSS people,
when they wrote the paper,
what scenarios did they use?
>> Yeah.
I think they were
using the original.
I think they're kind of
looking at two things
or they were originally
looking at like
a traditional PIR kind
of situation where now,
instead of looking for an index,
we can kind of like we don't
have to index things
ahead of time,
we can just like match
or record directly.
And they were also kind
of thinking about like
situations where
you want to kind of
compute like
a distributed function.
So I think there were kind
of trying to think of it like
a multi-party
computation sense or kind
of maybe I just want to
form out kind of
a computation but they
weren't very specific.
I think a lot of it was they
were inspired by kind of
PIR and secret sharing
and kind of
seeing can we get better
performance by looking at that.
>> Next question. So why
was joint hard for
you to support?
>> Sorry?
>> So you said you
don't support joint?
>> Yeah.
>> Why?
>> So it's not clear
how you do FSS.
You can kind of
think about joining
having materialized views and
joining a lot of databases.
We can support that in
that way but we don't have
a very clean way to kind
of support that joint.
I imagine you can
use some form of by
private set intersection in kind
of work with emphasize
in that but it
wasn't clear to us immediately
how to do that joint.
And so, for flights,
we have a much larger database
to kind of find
the top ten cheapest
flights between
two destinations takes
less than 40 milliseconds.
To do average monthly price
or top ten cheapest flights,
only took a few kilobytes
in terms of communication.
And we can do map routing
in about 1.2 seconds.
And all of these queries
had less than
1.6 seconds and response time
on a real network.
And many queries could be
run in hundreds of milliseconds.
And so most queries,
I wanted to round trips
and all queries had
communication much smaller
than the size of the database.
And so although we're slower
than running
the queries natively,
Splinter can perform
common web application queries
very practically and more
practical in the prior systems.
In the next slide, I'll
show you how Splinter
compares to other schemes.
Yeah.
>> So, the top 10
Mexican restaurant and
top 10 cheapest Flights,
are they similar? Are
the cores similar?
>> Yeah. The cores are similar.
>> The flight has
a larger database and
Yelp has smaller database,
but then the
communication cost with
the flight is much
less than Yelp's case.
>> Sorry, you are saying
that the communication
for the Yelp.
>> For the flight. The Flights
that are taking to
a larger database,
with only 4k and a 20k.
>> Right.
>> For as the restaurant,
you need to download
the pfs of the menus.
>> So can you call out
with that difference?
>> I think in the top
10 cheapest flights,
the flight table,
the flight records itself
are smaller and the records
for the restaurant were bigger.
So the flight,
we actually return numbers
and the restaurant,
we actually return
strings and so it is going
to be a little bit bigger.
It's based on
the specific record size.
So like there is a big database
but the records size
vary and the record size
for Yelp is bigger.
There are more records in this,
a lot more but
each record in individual
record size is smaller.
>> Do you need to
return all of them?
>> No, you don't
need to return all
of them but you need to return
a row of the database.The
row of the database,
like the information in
that data base is bigger.
>> Which one has more rows?
Can you go back?
There is one side there
that I remember [inaudible].
The flight has
30 times more rows.
>> Yes, it's 30 times
more rows but it
is only 10x bigger
in terms of size.
So that means it has
30x more rows but is
10x bigger in
size, in megabytes.
So each row is
actually much smaller.
Have like a video , row
per kilobyte or
whatever or megabyte.
And so when we return it,
we have to return
the whole row, right.
We want to return the whole row
like information the whole row.
>> [inaudible]
>> Yes.
>> Does the cost of the FSS
depend on the size of [inaudible]?
>> Yes, it does. The performance
of FSS like how many
times you do FSS,
depends on the size of
the domain of the input.
So the domain of X.
So if the domain
of X is 32 bits,
you have to perform
FSS 32 times.
Because it has a bit
by bit comparison.
>> [inaudible]
>> So, let's see.
So we're not using
all 64 cores in everything,
but we use one core in
everything but the routing.
The routing we use 64-cores.
>> Did you try to
use a 32 cores,
so last cores or two cores will
change the response time
significantly?
>> So I did for
the other ones and
it didn't change
substantially and
the reason is there's
some caching we do
because if you know
the answer to an FSS query,
for example, I do FSS
on the number two,
for a given query that will be
the same answer for
every time the output
of that will be the
same every time.
So the caching I didn't get it
to work across multiple cores.
I tried to but it seemed
like the caching was
pretty efficient and so if you
use multiple cores
like the caching,
they compete for the cache.
But it did, the map routing
had- we used the cache.
The cache hit was a lot less
and so that's why
I think it worked
better with more cores. Yes.
>> What's the reason for using
a machine with 64 cores?
>> We wanted to have a run
like on a realistic machine.
For us, like this routing
where we're saying we
wanted to running on
like a machine like
an actual provider would have.
>> MSN has machines
with line 1 core,
2 core, 8 cores.
Are they not realistic?
>> They are realistic, but if
I am a big web service
or I'm a provider,
I do really have
multiple machines I don't have
a machine with a single core.
>> But why 64 cores?
It is a bit arbitrary.
It was a little bit
arbitrary but we wanted to
find a beefy machine
to see how it scales.
If certain things would
scale with more cores.
>> [inaudible]
>> No, I don't have to regress.
So yes, but most of these
actually happen on one core.
>> Can you tell a little bit more
about the caching? [inaudible]
>> Let's assume
within one query.
If I do FSS,
let's say the record number
is 5 or something.
So if I have 575,
when you apply the FSS to 5,
it gives an output
of an integer.
And then that's the same if
you apply FSS to 5 again.
So it's like
deterministic across
the query. That make sense?
>> [inaudible]
>> No, because
for a given query,
FSS on 5 is the same.
A different query,
it's different.
Multiple brows may have
the same thing like
a database and so we
can just cache that.
You can imagine for flights,
it could be like
the same destination pair
might happen at many times
for multiple times
between two destination pairs.
>> [inaudible].
>> Right, but we don't
know where the query
is ahead of time, right?
>> [inaudible] which is essentially
doing the same thing [inaudible] right at
that point you know so
you could run through
walls and then yes I want to
wish for the fastest speed
possible feature
to actually use
[inaudible] your cache.
>> I see.
So you're saying,
that if I know ahead of
time what that FSS query is.
>> Like saying you get
my understanding is you'll
construct a temporary table
if it's a mean he's saying
if you do the sum, [inaudible]
>> Yes, you could.
But I mean, I think,
you have to do this for
all the variations of
the columns, right?
Because if I do
like a sum on the,
I got to do this for
all combinations of key sum.
Here right in the example,
it's a little bit
simplistic because my table has
two columns but it could have
multiple columns and I have
to do the sum for everything.
I mean, I could. I could.
I mean, just put more storage
and I could speed it up.
That is a possibility.
But you have to increase
your storage size subset.
>> You don't want to
pre-compute all this.
>> Yeah, I mean, so some of
these you can imagine for
Top Ten and stuff like that,
you can pre-compute
like common ones.
You can play some
of these database,
common database tricks to
make this a little bit faster.
If you have a lot of comments,
SQL queries this happens
like an Oracle database or
like a SAP database.
If you see queries
are very common,
you could have pre-compute
some views to make it go faster.
That's definitely possible.
Here, we just don't assume that.
Cool. So, we compare Splinter to
a state-of-the-art
system by Olumofin,
which is most similar
onto Splinter in terms
of supported queries.
And for similar queries
and databases,
Splinter has up to
an order of magnitude,
lower response times
compared to Olumofin.
And the number of round trips
for their system is
proportional to log factor of
the database which is about ten.
And for Splinter, most queries
only take a constant number
of round trips,
and takes log in only
for a very select few.
And the lower round trips
is especially useful in
high-latency networks
where these types of
web applications are
commonly used. Yes?
>> What is the
Olumofin based on?
>> So, they're based on
information theoretic PIR.
>> You said you run
their code on your databases?
>> I didn't run
their code on my database.
So, I kind of compared kind
of in terms of round trip times.
In terms of number
of round trips, how
many it would take?
If I ran their query,
how many it would take?
And how many round trips
it would take,
that's kind of easy to compute
based on their algorithm.
>> Okay. So, it's just
an estimate based on
the round-trip time that
you said assumed in your.
>> Yeah,
so these run-through
response times are actually like
them without
any network latency.
And so, I mean, I'm
just kind of showing you
these numbers to kind of
see the range is much
different than the range here.
That's the purpose
of this slide.
>> What if you have
zero record latency, I mean,
vary with the response time,
maybe it's a dumb question.
Why would the response
time be so high?
>> Because the computation is
heavy. Right? You're using.
>> Something about the hardware
for the computation, right?
If there's some cost model
computation that we have.
>> Right.
>> What is that?
So, I mean, did
you come up with,
I'm missing, kind of trying
to understand where did
you get those numbers from?
>> So yeah, the numbers.
So this, the top numbers
out of the paper,
like they are paper
to kind of like this.
>> As in the same database
that you had.
>> It was like
a similar size database.
>> And same hardware?
>> It's similar hardware, yeah.
>> Okay. And similar
network conditions?
>> No, they had
no network conditions.
I mean, I think
this is kind of like
we didn't do a very
direct comparison.
I mean, these numbers could
be kind of like fudged a
little bit and it would change
if we actually went and
performed what they had.
But I think the goal of this
was trying to just show.
For them, they have to use
information theoretic PIR.
It's a totally different model
than what we use.
I mean, I think the comparison
is not 100% fair,
like I can admit that.
But I'm just giving you a sense
of like this is what
it would, potentially.
>> That makes sense,
in some sense.
>> I mean, I mean.
Sure. I mean, I think a lot
of this like we thought about.
I mean, it's just like
a completely different model.
We have much fewer round
trips than they do.
So, it's like how do you,
we can kind of model that too.
I mean, I think those
are all possible things.
>> On the other hand
the computation of
the server put them
at cheaper, right?
Because they're adjusting
xSource in some sense.
>> Yeah, but they're not really
doing xSource though
because they, I mean,
they are doing xSource but
they have to do a lot of
pre-computation
like on the demand
on computation when you use PIR.
Because they only have
this tool that allows him
to query for an index.
So they kind of have to
like do a lot more work.
So, how you kind of,
I think we can kind of think of
different models and convincing
models that kind of think of it.
But it's, there's
multiple ways we can model it.
But I think just in general,
the point of this is to
give you a vague sense.
I'm not claiming we
beat them by so much.
But I'm saying like
then, the numbers are so
different like the point is like
the numbers are so
different, right?
That's only the kind of
point I'm trying to
make with this slide.
>>Did you ask Olumofin
for their code?
>>I did, but they
didn't respond.
Which is I think
maybe I think he had
graduated a long time ago.
And so, this is like
a three or four-year-old paper
at least and so.
>> Implementations on IT PIR?
>> Yeah.
Yeah, I mean I didn't
try but I mean, we
could have tried.
Yeah. I think they
use when one of these
like IT PIR kind of like
libraries out there so.
Cool. Yeah, so there's
been a bunch of
work on practical
private query systems.
And Splinter is
also related to work
on PIR systems and
garbled circuits.
But Splinter is more
practical compared to
those other systems.
The practical
private query systems
suffer from some combination
of limited functionality,
heavy leakage, and bad scaling.
In PIR, a user can privately
query for a relaxed record,
or for a record at index
I without the servers
learning the index
or the response.
However, not much work
has been done on building
very practical PIR
systems that can
perform realistic
application queries.
Typically state of
the art PIR systems use
multiparty information through
PIR for performance reasons.
And even though with
that, these systems
require many round trips,
high communication costs for
the type of queries
that Splinter supports.
But because we use FSS,
we'd get around a lot of
these performance issues.
And with information
theoretic PIR,
to get the performance
that require
that no priors collude,
while in Splinter, we allow
all but one to collude
with each other.
Isn't PIR just one provider
or multiple providers.
>> There's different
PIR kind of schemes.
So, the more efficient
ones obviously,
they assume none of the
providers can collude but there's
a lot of, information theoretic,
it's the very common ones
either like a minority,
or a slight majority
collude, or none collude.
But you can also imagine
information theoretic scheme,
or all but one collude
also but you kind of get
into heavier
communication costs.
And then, computational
PIR is like
a different scheme that's like
a trustless scheme, right?
And so, and their communication
and computation costs
are much higher.
>> So, FSS is your core
technique in some sense critical.
>> That's a core like
crypto building block, yeah.
>> Different PIR has
some other crypto primitives.
So, what is the key when
you compare them that
enables you to be
better than PIR schemes?
>> Yeah, I mean, I think the
biggest difference between,
I think funny to sharing is
like just very different.
Because one it's like
an expressive PIR,
or kind of like
if you think of it
because now you don't
have to have an index,
you kind of can match records,
you can do less
than greater than,
which is actually not
possible in PIR directly.
Like of course, you can play
some tricks to make it work.
And I think their information
directly are, they do xSource.
And so, they kind of require
multiple servers
to different model
but in computational PIR,
you have to use
public key cryptography,
and we use one wave function.
So, I think we kind
of stand in the middle
between in terms of kind of
assumptions wise between
cryptographic
assumptions between
information theoretic
and computational PIR.
So, I think it's
just a different model.
I think it's hard to directly
compare because they all
provide different features.
But I think the expressiveness
is the very key features.
And the expressiveness with
the kind of like what
we call any trust,
or like one non-colluding
server assumption is like,
I think very strong.
I mean, an interesting and
kind of like model to look at.
>> Quick question.
So, the advantage
of using three servers over
two servers is that it's harder
for three servers to collude
because they need
to all collude.
>> Yeah. So, in that case,
like two servers
can be malicious.
>>Two servers, is
there any other?
other than [inaudible] to use
three servers rather than two.
I think, the clue thing
is the main thing.
It's a little bit faster for
larger databases just because
the scheme is a
little bit different,
but the disadvantage
with why it's a
little bit faster is like now,
you have more
communication costs
because just current FSS
with three or more parties,
the factor depends on
the number of parties,
and where in two-server doesn't.
So it's just kind of
have the scheme works.
I think it's a very new scheme.
I think there's a lot
of work that needs
to be done both on
that side and kind of like
thinking more about what's
going on. So continue.
Garbled circuits, they are
secure computation tool through
parties to privately evaluate
a function by
using this tool has
very high computation
and communication costs
in our specific setting.
And so to a kind of conclude
this Splinter part of the talk,
so current web services leak
sensitive information
to user queries.
I presented to
you Splinter which
is the first system that uses
an extends FSS with
new protocols to efficiently
protect these queries.
Splinter-enabled versions
of realistic applications
are fast and secure.
And so I've now to talk
to you about Splinter.
I'll talk to you a little
bit about future work.
It's fashionable.
So have you evaluated under
mutational cost [inaudible].
>> Yeah. So we do
have in our paper.
So we can look at Amazon costs.
So I know one query.
If It's not a Maps query,
it's a regular query,
costs about ¢0.01.
It's like less than a cent,
ensures a computational cost in
terms like if you do
a kind of timing match.
I mean we did this a lot of
research before
the times of serverless.
And so I think if you run on
a serverless, it
could be much cheaper.
But we kind of
assume how much time
of that web server
it was taking.
It was less than ¢0.01.
But the result
privacy protection,
how much will it cost?
It will be very fast.
I think it's hard to really
make that comparison.
>> [inaudible].
>> Yeah, about probably
three orders of magnitude.
The reason is because we
can't do a lot of
the traditional tricks
that a database can.
So like a database
heavily engineered,
like they have
scope of everything.
They can do query planning
that we cannot,
they can have optimized rows,
and they have hundreds of
engineers who are going to type,
optimize the crap out of
a database, and so on.
And they're very cognizant
performance, etc., etc.
Josh, this scheme is
very caching-unfriendly.
Yeah, it's very
caching unfriendly.
We do some caching,
but very unfriendly,
like you have to
pay storage costs.
I think it's because it's
like you have security,
you don't have a view of
certain amounts of information.
Like in a sequel databases,
if you know everything,
you can plan for it.
Yeah. So here's some kind
of follow on work.
So Splinter is
reduced overhead for
private carries
by leveraging FSS.
But it's really
only the beginning.
I think some of you guys brought
up some kind of
follow on work or
some interesting work
that needs to be done.
The amount of data in these
web services is only growing,
and users expect
more expressive queries.
And so it's not clear
how we can scale
the billions or trillions
of records with this scheme,
how we can have
more expressive queries
like joins and knots,
how we improve efficiency for
really four or more servers,
like I said, for two or three,
it's pretty efficient,
and from four, it doesn't
scale as well because
FSS technique does not scale
as well past four servers.
And so some future directions,
we've been thinking
about and trying to make
more progress on is like how
can we do some forward PAR,
FSS with pre-processing
so we don't have to
look through the whole database
every single time.
So I think that helps on
the billions or trillions
of records part,
like how can we design
a more expressive FSS
to solve the expressive
queries part.
Maybe this just requires
new cryptographic tools for
systems or new cryptographic
Pierre FSS scheme, like schemes.
And so on a related topic PIR
and FSS and multiparty
computation,
MPC have pretty
strong connections.
And in FSS, we wanted
to hide the function,
but the input was public.
However, MPCs are
reverse problem.
We want to hide the input,
but the function is public.
And so, more concretely,
we have four values,
X1 through X4, and we
want to compute
a known function on it.
However, the servers want
to know the result
of the function,
but they don't want to
reveal their respective input
to other servers.
And so why is this useful?
Organizations are storing
more and more data in the cloud,
and data is becoming
more digitize.
However, many times
organizations
might want to keep their data
proprietary but might
be willing to compute
a shared function or
selectively store data.
And so, for example,
patients might visit
different hospitals
for various conditions.
As a result, not one hospital
has a complete view of
the patient's health.
So imagine this for
millions of patients.
Similarly, many patients might
have a similar condition,
but a single hospital
will only have
a sparse data set to
do research on this.
But across many hospitals,
there could be a richer dataset.
And so in the current world,
medical researchers
could be missing
key insights because
the data is so fragmented.
But with MPC you have a way
to share and analyze
this data in a secure way.
And so the reason MPC is
not used frequently in
practice is because of
a poor performance both in
computation and bandwidth.
So an interesting future
direction is to make
garbled circuit systems
more efficient.
Some recent work out of
Berkeley has shown that
corporate circuits can be
somewhat practically in systems,
but they have
limited functionality.
The goal is to kind of
expand the functionality
of the garbled circuit systems
and make them more practical.
Similarly, there's
related FSS technique
called homomorphic
circuit sharing,
which kind of reverses this.
And so for them,
the function is public,
but the input is private also,
and they do that for
branching programs.
And so you can kind of
imagine it being more expressive
with more functionality also.
And another extension
for MPC is to find
ways to maybe do MPC on
graphs more efficiently,
which is a common data
structure commonly
insecurity as people try
to contextualize and
respond to threats.
And so I'm excited to
continue collaborating
with both cryptographers
and systems researchers to
solve these problems and find
new systems applications for
a lot of these
cryptographic tools.
And so I want to thank
all my wonderful collaborators
that have made my PhD possible.
And so there are folks from
systems and cryptography.
And so I've also had a lot
of wonderful discussions
with companies like
Akamai, Rapid7,
and provider to kind of
help me identify and
motivate a lot of
these research problems.
Yeah. Thanks.
I have a high level point,
which is now, if
this technology is widely used,
then the provider cannot have
learned some useful things
like the route number five
is hot or Thai
restaurant is popular.
Have you thought about
any technology that still allows
the provider to do
some statistical learning?
Yeah. I think it's hard
within this model where
its goal is kind of
hiding this information.
If you have new information,
it's hard to kind of do
some statistical learning.
I think you can imagine
kind of a world where
someone does these
aggregates independently.
For example, like you know
either anonymously or
where some third party
does aggregation like using
multiparty computation
or something like that.
But I think that's
a separate problem,
and you can't learn it from
the query directly like it's
some separate system that's
kind of collecting a lot
of this information and
kind of aggregating it.
Yeah. And if you
care, we're trying to
really prevent aggregates
from happening.
But in the flight case,
to the final purchase of ticket,
that information
still can be used
to do marketing or just a price.
Yeah. In that case, it would be.
But you kind of
prevent the problem
where multiple people look
for a certain flight and
they raise the price
as a result.
But if you purchase
a flight ticket, sure.